Packing Up
We're going camping!
We pack our tent, sleeping bags, and cooking gear.
"Don't forget the camera!" I say.
We drive to the lake, and we set up camp.
Click! I take a picture.
Nighttime
"Time to eat," says Dad.
We build a fire to cook hamburgers and hotdogs.
Click! I take a picture.
"Time for bed," says Mom.
We get into our sleeping bags.
We look at the stars.
Click! I take a picture.
Bear and Fish
In the morning, we see a bear by the lake.
It is eating berries.
Click! I take a picture.
"Time for fishing," says Dad.
Mom catches three fish, and Abby catches a turtle.
Click! I take a picture.
Time to Go Home
Our camping trip is over, and it's time to go home.
Click! I take a picture.
The next day, Grandma wants to hear all about our trip.
I can't remember everything . . .
. . . so I show Grandma all my pictures!